[Music]
all right hello hello everyone welcome
back to Grand Masters Choice today we're
going to pick off what we left off last
time we're going to go through some
tactics on the leeches tactics trainer
see if we can solve them together so if
you're there in the twitch chat as well
feel free to chime in share your
thoughts and your moves in the twitch
chat I'll be monitoring that as well so
we've got the first position up here
it's white to play so what do we think
is going on here what most come to
mind is there's something in Black's
position that we think we can
Target so when you're solving tactics
you want to think about forcing move
first those usually take the form of
check or an exchange or a
capture so do we have any of those in
this
position
so it doesn't seem like we can exchange
anything right we have a queen and a
bishop but can't really exchange them
with anything Black's got a queen and a
Rog so he is an exchange up we're down
material which means we have to act
quickly otherwise the extra material is
going to make a difference so what about
Black's King is there any way which we
can check Black's King Bishop okay
Bishop where on
age Okay so Bishop H6 very good so not
only do we give a check to the king but
we attack The Rook as well so now we
have to calculate what happens after
black mov his King
back so let's say Bishop H6 King G8 What
do we do next do we grab the Rook
immediately or do we have something
stronger sup Patrick yeah those are good
candidate
moves
well these tactics aren't supposed to be
super difficult so even if they look
easy don't second guess
yourself so Bishop H6 check King G8
black has to keep the Rook on f8
protected so it'd be great if we can
dislodge the king from protecting The
Rook then we just win The Rook for free
so is there any way which we can do
that
okay very good so Queen E6 check we
attack the king if he moves to the side
then we grab the Rook so now the
question remains after Bishop H6 King G8
Queen E6 check what if Black Blocks with
Rook
F7 so he's holding on for dear
life got to play one more move there to
win that Rook
cleanly
Patrick that's a good idea I don't think
it works though there's a defense for
black and it's it's similar it's a
similar defense to one that black has
after Rook F7 I'll show it
afterwards so Rook
F7 what are the checks in the position
the bishop on H6 there is potential to
create a mating net around Black's King
so Bishop H6 his King drops back slideer
Queen into E6 and he blocks with Rook F7
so we're so close to winning that Rook
but we got to make one more
move we have two checks which we have to
consider in that position we have queen8
check right hitting the queen from the
back Rank and we have Queen takes G6
check wining this pawn and also
attacking the king so the question is
which
one should we go for there only one of
those moves win the other leads to I
think a
draw so we got to calculate that out
carefully yeah Patrick that's one of the
ideas Queen E8 but does black have a
defense there so after Queen
E8 we hit the king and we attack attack
The Rook he can block Rook f8 cuz the
bishop on H6 covering that square so is
there a way which he can get out of that
let me just remove those arrows so
Bishop H6 King G8 Queen E6 Rook F7 Queen
E8 hitting the king hitting the Rook he
can block but does black have a defense
there yeah very good Patrick I think you
yeah I think you figured it figured it
out and yeah that's why Queen D7 would
not
work all right so maybe let's make the
first few moves so it's a bit easier to
visualize so Bishop
H6 King G8 all right we got that right
Queen E6 check Rook F7 perfect this is
where we're at so again Queen E8 Queen
takes G6 two candidate
moves so it's just move by move
calculation here we got to anticipate
what our opponent will play after either
move and then just compare which one
looks
better okay so someone likes Queen E8
someone likes Queen G6 all right so
Queen E8
check do you have a response for black
there um even if they block Bishop
um has yeah very good so Rook f8 is not
possible we can just take that because
The Bishop's covering it but this does
he have another
move think about all those possibilities
there there's only one other move in the
position right so what's the other legal
move
there uh we'll come back to that I just
want to figure out why Queen E8 doesn't
work so Queen E8 check what's the
defense for
black well if he moves his Rook the f8
square is covered right we've got the
bishop and the Queen so he can't do that
but he has another move so Queen E8
check how does black defend
there King h k King H7 yeah okay very
good so Queen E8 King
H7 seems like that shouldn't work
because we can take the Rook but our
Bishop's also hanging he takes our
Bishop back and all of a sudden we we
lose our attacking potential there so
try to imagine this position Queen E8
King H7 Queen F7 King H6 we just get
into a queen end game and Black's King
escapes so Queen E8 is no good so Queen
takes G6 what about
that Black Blocks we take the
Rook black moves his King
over yeah very good we take the Rook on
F7 and we win the rook and our King is
safe on D2 so we don't have to worry
about any Perpetual check from the queen
all right so let's do that Queen G6 King
h8 and yep Queen takes F7 so let's go
back here there was a suggest in the
chat Bishop H6 King G8 Queen D7 and
again this looks very strong a
threatening M seems like black has no
defense but there's this move again Rook
F7 and the same idea as we saw on the
other line Queen a check King H7 and
black king escapes because of the attack
on the H6 Bishop so that's why King G8
it's important to go Queen E6 check Rook
S7 and then not get tempted by this move
simply Slide the queen over here and
Black's position falls
apart
all right so let's go to the next
one okay so we got a pawn L game here
the first move is obvious so why took
our Queen we will take
back all right so now we got to think
here not many pieces on the board so
again move by move calculation it's
clear that our idea should be to promote
the pawn we also have to worry about
White's Pawn
promoting so in what direction should we
start thinking here should we just move
our King anywhere and start ramming our
Pawn down the board or is there a
strategic way which we can maneuver our
King firstly let's just count so let's
say we move the king somewhere random
let's just say here for now white goes
G5 we go B3 white goes G6 Black Goes B2
white goes G7 we promote and he promotes
at the same time and that's just a draw
right queen versus queen so we know that
that pushing our Pawn down
aimlessly is not going to work because
white Queen's at the same time that
means we got to use our
King the question is how what's the role
of the king going to
be again White's only source of
counterplay is a g Pawn so how can we
use our King what should the king's role
be
here King
where it's black perspective so this
would be
C C4 okay and what's the
idea so let's say I go
G5 yep very good so the king is just
going to come back to help protect
against this Pawn so let's count king C4
G5 King D5 G6 King E6 G7 King F7 we
catch that pawn if white can't promote
the pawn it's just game over because his
king is too far from our Pawn so once we
stop this Pawn then we can continue on
with our Pawn advance so King
C4 G5 King D5
G6 exactly what we said and King
F7 yep we just take the
queen and white can prevent black from
promoting so it's important here not to
just rush into getting into a pawn race
here we got to think about our
opponent's counterplay he wants to he
wants the same thing as us so we can use
our King to stop
that yeah it is a bit counterintuitive
Patrick so it seems like why are we
putting our King on the
same diagonal and the same color Square
as White's promotion Square could be a
check potentially but again we got to
calculate it move by move right just
because something looks wrong doesn't
mean it's necessarily wrong so King C4
G5 King D5 the goal is to catch that
pawn with our King and once you realize
that we can catch it then it becomes
very clear that this is the correct move
because we get rid of White's only
source of counterplay and then our Pawn
is free to
advance all right next one back in the
middle game
here so what's going on what sticks out
immediately in the
position let's look at White's pieces
particular the
defile does that queen look like it
could run into issues on the D file and
if so why
look at how our pces are lined
up yep good job
Patrick so this queen on
D5 what do we have on the dile that
could potentially create create issues
for this
queen yeah okay very good The Rook but
Bishop's also kind of correct so we have
this Rook here on the D file could be a
potential discovered move with our
Bishop so imagine we could move this
bishop to a square which attacks the
queen it unleashes this attack it also
attacks something else in White's
position creating a double
attack if we can do that we'll just win
material because white will have to
react to his Queen being under attack
after he saves his Queen we can pick up
the other piece which we were attacking
so is there a square which we can move
our Bishop to that accomplishes
this where g g G4 yeah Bishop G4 very
good so we attacked the queen and we
attack that Rook at the back and I don't
think white can defend there so let's
try it Bishop G4 yep very good goes
Queen E4 and we grab that rook and we
just win an
exchange all right that was pretty
straightforward uh
next one another Pawn end game so again
move by move here not many pieces in the
board so we need to calculate this out
carefully theoretically it should be
easier to do that there only what six
pieces on the
board it should be clear now what our
goal should be in this
position King F7 okay think about it
first don't just rush
okay very good so King G8 so we need to
understand here that our goal should be
to pick up this Pawn on H5 and
potentially the F5 Pawn as well we need
to attack the the white pawns because
our King is very
passive if we play a move like King F7
he'll take the opposition and this King
will slowly enter into the position
we'll have to keep giving up ground
we'll probably lose the game there move
like King G8 though all of a sudden
we're going after these
pawns so let's see King G8 King
E6 King H7 King F7 so White's trying to
attack the G7 Pawn as well King
H6 King
G8 what's happening
there so the point is if we take on H5
want white wants to take on G7 so is
that the end of the line or do we have
something at the
end yep you should be worried about that
but we still have to calculate that line
right because if it works then we just
win the game we pick up both the whes
pawns so again King G8 King E6 King H7
King F7 King H6 and white comes down to
G8 he's trying to keep contact with his
G7 pawn and his idea is if we take on H5
he takes and
G7 so now you have to figure out is that
the end of the variation or do we have
another move at the end there
the how do you push the
pawn you mean the G Pawn the G6 you mean
like here but that would just give it
the pawn right and even if you go G5
white always his on pant so King G8 King
E6 King H7 King F7 King H6 King
G8 we need to figure out is that winning
for black or do we have to look for
something
else yep guys in the chat have got it
good
job again King takes H5 at the end of
that line King takes G7 so our King now
is on H5 try to visualize that White's
King on G7 and the only pawns remaining
are F5 and
F6 and this king is also now threatening
to take on F6
there so is that it or do we have
something
there yep good job
SG take
have to
prot yep very good that's it so at the
end we just have King
G5 we defend the F6 pawn and we're
attacking the F5 pawn and white can stop
that and once we take the F5 Pawn his
King is so badly out of position that we
we be able to run our F Pawn down the
board so King G8 yep King E6 King H7 all
right he's trying King D5 doesn't matter
let's look at the main line here King F7
King H6 so this is the line which we
were trying to work out king H5 King G7
and we need to see King G5 at the end
there otherwise we lose right because he
takes the F6 Pawn we have this King G5
move which protects it and attacks F5
and this king is just so bad now can't
get back in time to stop this Pawn for
instance
this King can just keep shouldering the
white king and this F Pawn is going to
roll down the
board all right
okay wow this looks horrible for
black our Rook is so passive it's stuck
protecting the C Pawn from promoting his
King is more active than
ours our structure is terrible
everything about this
looks looks like it should be a lost
position but maybe we have some hidden
resource
here could white be overextended
somewhere
so it's clear if we move our
King whichever way we go he's going to
go the other way so King E7 for ex for
example King G6 his King penetrates King
G7 King E6 we don't want to allow his
King to get into our
position so we need to we need to leave
the King on F7 to keep this King out
it's doing a good job of doing that is
there somewh which we can activate this
Rook with a
threat again you have to be very careful
where you move this Rook because if you
move it to the wrong Square you're just
going to allow white to promote for
free so there's somewhere we can move
this Rook which creates a threat in the
position look at White's King it could
be potentially
trapped yep very good so Rook
E8 with the threat R
off5 yeah Rook E5 exactly and white
can't stop this it's just made after
Rook E8 we take away that E4 Square
suddenly White's King is trapped and
Rook E5 is
Unstoppable so Rook e eight all right he
tries Rook e three doesn't matter we're
just going to take that rook and
whenever he promotes we give mate on the
center of the board kind of amusing that
we're able to Checkmate Checkmate white
there despite having such a bad
position just shows you that there can
be hidden moves you and in bad
positions okay so what was Black's last
Mo oh okay he grabbed our Knight there
so he just took our piece can't take
back asz it's pinned so let's not think
about
that but we have some action going on
here around Black's King on the queen
side got an open a file it's Pawn on B6
is doing stuff could potentially take
this
so we can generate some threats
here so it seems to me that there are
only two moves we need to consider
taking that pawn on A7 with the pawn or
taking with the Rook we need to figure
out which one is
better so what do you guys think what
looks more
intuitive should we take with the pawn
should we take with the
Rook okay with with the idea of
so Rook A7 what's the idea what's your
next move if you had one more
move like Rook A8 it's not mate though
because he can block with Knight B8 it's
almost M but he has this backward knight
move which defends everything Knight B8
and I don't see how you would make
progress there seems like he's covering
all the
threats okay so taking with the pawn now
that has a direct threat we're
threatening to
promote
I'm not sure what we play after King C7
though or maybe yeah I think maybe we
have some ideas there
[Music]
actually this is a tricky position so
Pawn takes so we're threatening to
promote okay he moves his King up I
think I see an idea for white there so
ba A7 King C7 try to come up with an
idea there for
white again keep in mind that this queen
on
F4 the G Pawn is pinned but if we can
deflect that Rook somehow that Queen's
going to be under attack so see if we
can incorporate that into our to our
move
here
King C7 opens up the Rooks right to
protect the a square but maybe that Rook
on G8 could be potentially
overloaded it's trying to do too many
things keep this Pawn pinned and keep
this Pawn from promoting so can we
exploit
that
do you mean C5 here or in the next
position after King
C7 I don't think it works in either
position
though CU I would just take on
C5 but I see your point you're trying to
open up the queen to attack this Rook
but I think we have an even better move
so B A7 King
C7
again think about moves that seemingly
don't
work black may have covered the a square
but
maybe we still have some ideas connected
with pushing that
pawn
well that's a very legit legitimate
concern Patrick it's definitely
something which we'll look at so now try
to figure out how we escape with our
King so what are you guys thinking after
King C7 let's hear some candidate
moves
any
ideas we' got a suggestion in the chat
from a very terrible chess player I'll
address that
later so he's suggesting after King C7
to promote a A8 Knight he's trying to be
funny so B8 King C7 but again that
should give you guys a
hint well no we don't want to promote to
a knight we want to do something a bit
more
forceful
Queen what's the most powerful piece
Queen okay so let's say we promote to a
queen so what's the point there black
just takes what do we do
now
take the Rook okay we take the Rook what
if he
takes the queen yeah very good now the
queen is hanging so all of a sudden
after B A7 King C7 A8 Queen like I said
The Rook on G is overloaded so he can
take
once but we take back and since he can't
take twice we just want an exchange
we'll have a rook we'll have two Rooks
and a queen versus the queen rook and
Knight
so B A7 King C7 seemingly stopping A8
but actually we can still play that move
and we win the
exchange so the only thing there which
we would have to calculate is this Rook
sack on G3 which could result in a
Perpetual but I don't think it does so
let's look at that b A7 King
C7 Queen take take all right they
stopped the line here so let's look at
what we were discussing if he takes all
of a sudden the pin is gone we take the
queen if he does not nothing well he
just lost an exchange basically and
we're going to have a winning
position so let's say he tries Rook
takes G3 check H takes G3 Queen takes G3
so his idea is after King H1 he'll play
Queen H3 and he'll keep checking our
King in the hopes of making a
draw oops sorry Queen G3 check but if we
just calculate for a few more moves we
see that our King escapes quite easily
if we run this way King F1 again the
material deficit is huge we have two
Rooks and a queen he has got a queen and
a knight so if you can't find a
Perpetual check here the game's just
going to be over whites up so much
material so Queen
H3 King E1 and our goal is basically to
just run that King over to the queen
side imagine the king getting to
B1 that would just be absolutely safe so
King E1 Queen G3 King D3 no matter where
he checks from our King will always find
a safe heaven here can try this doesn't
matter we go here and he runs out of
checks very easily so that would would
just be the final thing which we need to
make sure when we when we make a move
like this that Rook takes Sho two
doesn't
work uh let's see are there any other
tricky checks he can
try Queen H4 nope our King runs
anyways all right so let's go to the
next
one okay so what's going on
here material balance Black's up an
exchange right we've got two Bishops and
a knight he's only got a bishop and
Knight but he's got an extra Rook he's
got two Rooks you got one Rook so we're
down in exchange he just took on A2
could be potentially attacking our King
we got to watch out for moves like Queen
A1 hitting the king and also hitting
that
Bishop but we do have some strengths in
the
position so what looks weak in Black's
position
look okay there could be potential along
this
diagonal what else is there are there
some squares in particular that are weak
in Black's
position yeah very good the dock Square
he's missing the the dark squared Bishop
this
diagonal could create serious issues for
black there
potentially those are two motives which
we identified potential ideas along this
diagonal and along this diagonal
so we also have to like I said watch out
for Queen A1 Queen F1 so we got to act
quickly so what's a forcing move here
that creates some serious threats in
Black's
position Bishop Bishop
where is that
protected he can just take the bishop
right so we don't want to
rush so again
look at this diagonal in particular
focus on
that we've got a killer dark Square
Bishop on D4 he doesn't have a dark squ
Bishop defending his
King so what's a way which we can use
that what piece can be can we combine
with that Bishop to create a serious
threat
huh Queen here
where here yes yep very good so Queen E5
so we're threatening a mate on h8 that's
a serious threat he can't run because
Queen h8 is made anyways so after Queen
E5 he's got to try to block this
diagonal the only way you can do that is
Rook
F6 so now we got to continue our
calculation where do we go from
there so our thinking should be centered
around getting rid of that F6 Bishop F6
Rook so what's protecting that F6
Rook right the pawn on E7 protecting The
Rook if that pawn Falls his position
collapses because the Rook can no longer
block that
diagonal how do we get to that
pawn take it yep very good simply we
just take it Queen takes E7 now his
rook's hanging and there just too many
threats to deal with if his Rook can
block this
diagonal then our attack is just going
to crash through so I think that's the
solution let's try it Queen E5 okay Rook
F6
yep very good we take that pawn all
right he tries Knight
C6 so one more move we need to
play and we took on E7 we had a threat
what was
it Queen e h that's not mate though
right he can block Rook
f8 got to be careful it's attacking Our
Queen and our
Bishop
but when we took on E7 we had a
threat yep guys in the chat good
job yeah Bishop C4 doesn't
work so what was the threat when we took
on
E7 we undermine
something
take the Rook yeah very good just simply
take the Rook Queen takes F6 just pick
this Rook
up and then R up a piece after all that
so we get that exchange back but we also
win a piece he's got one two pieces we
got one two three and he's got these
weaknesses around the king so he has no
compensation at all so we just pick up
that rook and yeah game's
over okay next one
all right Queen F5 is the last
move so immediately we should see that
we have ideas on this file right Queen
takes B2 as a potential idea if we could
play that it'd be made but the Rook is
defending it so already we should start
to think of ways to get rid of that Rook
on B1 KN on
D2 okay KN on D2 that's definitely one
idea
um I think white has a sneaky move in
response
though I don't think 92 quite works but
there's it's the right idea but there's
another way of doing it I think which
stops White's counter
move so again look at that pressure on
that B
file yeah very good knight
C3 so Knight
C3 attacking that Rook he can't take cuz
it's mate and if he can't do anything
about it we're just going to pick up
that rope so let's try Knight C3 I think
it's correct let's just make
sure uh worried about some moves like
Knight H6
here but so basically my concern is
Knight H6 we can't take with the queen
because that would break the pin he can
then take the Knight so Knight C3 Knight
H6 G takes H6 got to make sure he
doesn't have some Queen check which also
attacks the Knight on C3 I don't think
he does though he could try Queen G4 but
then we go King h8 and he runs out of
checks so I think this is correct let's
try it
okay take with that pawn all right he
goes Queen E5 interesting so he's not
giving a check but he's attacking our
Knight so yep very good we just take
that Rook doesn't do anything to help
him so let's see why Knight D2 wasn't
working also looks good right it looks
like the same thing we're attacking that
Rook it can't move it because it's main
so what is uh what is white play
here find White's defense I'll flip the
board
even so look at the positioning of black
king and this Knight on
D2 yeah really good Patrick that's why
Knight C3 is is correct because it takes
away that
square so how does white save the game
here so he can't move the Rook we
already know that so we know it's got to
be something related to the Knight and
the
queen so his only hope is to create some
sort of counter threat against Black's
King so how can he do
that
yeah very good Queen
D5 exactly so Queen
D5 attacking the Knight on D2 and
setting up a discover check with the
Knight on F7 this Knight is ready to
move and it's going to do some
damage so that's why Knight D2 doesn't
work so another suggestion Knight Knight
takes H6 almost works but the difference
here now is that we can actually take
with the queen
compared to the Knight on the Knight C3
line we couldn't take with the queen
there because he can take but here the
queen protects the Knight and queen D5
wouldn't do anything the Knight is
protected but close that was the right
idea but instead Queen D5 our Knight's
unprotected and there's also a threat to
the a discover check threat to the black
king but yeah very important to see our
opponent's resources as well well seems
like the same move and it doesn't make a
difference but one of them wins the
other one allows probably a
draw so yeah Knight to3 was very precise
all right good
job okay back to another opponent
game all right so we have a decision he
just took our Pawn how do we
recapture without even calculating
instinctively what recapture makes more
sense what's the difference between if I
take with this Pawn the E Pawn and if I
take with the G
Pawn exactly if we take with the G Pawn
we create that pass Pawn for white
that's always going to be counterplay
that means we can never run our King
down to attack this F3 Pawn because this
H Pawn's always going to be a
problem so let's look at e takes
F4 what's our plan in this position
we're trying to get our King into the
enemy territory so we can pick up this
Pawn on F3 so ef4 he's going to try to
stop that let's say he goes King E2 so
he's ready to shoulder our King he's
trying to block it
out is he going to succeed or can we out
maneuver his
King well Patrick why why is e takes F4
necessarily A draw we have a more Ive
King
right and we prevent white from getting
a pass Pawn on the H
file so you make sure white doesn't have
any counterplay and we can potentially
have a way to use our King to infiltrate
the position White's King is very
passive but he has one hope here if we
go to the wrong score he's going to make
a draw so we need to be careful e takes
F4 King E2 how do we get into White's
position
when you calculate think wherever you
move your king how is white going to
react where is he going to position his
King in relation to your
king
King E5
um okay so ef4 King E2 King E5 right
King D4 I think all right King D4
another sis let's just look at King E5
so King
E5 what if they go King
D3 okay so are you trying to run your
king over to collect this yeah I think
we're a bit too slow though so King D4
uh H actually wait let's think this is
tricky so ef4 King E2 King E5 it's not
the move I was thinking about but we
still need to figure out if it works or
not so King E2 King
E5
um it's kind of similar to that other
opponent end game we had right we run
the king
over TR to go around yeah that's a good
idea h i
don't doesn't seem like it should work
but not seeing the defense for white
either so ef4 King E2 King
E5
um so I'm thinking King D3 King F5 King
D4 King G6
huh I'm not sure if I'm in time there
because again the same issue King E4
King H5 King's going to run up to H4
take on H3 and then at the end King G3
the same idea pick up the F3
Pawn so ef4 King E2 King
E5 I thought we had an easier win but
let's see King
E5 now we got to think about defensive
resources for white
guys in the chat help us out king E2
King E5 is their
defense so Black's idea is to run the
king over to H4 take on H3 and then play
King g3 at the end which would win so
white has to try to stop that
somehow and I'm having difficulty seeing
how
chasings
what
are
theying the chasing after each basically
yeah it's like it see it seems like that
other tactic right where we ran our King
to the corner when the King was back on
the backer went King G8 King H7 King
H6 so if black king gets to H4 it's over
because we're going to take on H3 why
will take on G5 and we have that King G3
move so I'm trying to figure out if
there's a way for white to stop that I'm
not seeing
it
okay let's play ef4 we know that's the
move okay King let's all right let's
solve the position and then we'll come
back to that that's very interesting I'm
curious if King E5 also wins because I
thought we had a simpler solution there
all right let's try to first get through
this part there so King E1 so White's
trying to be
clever so you wanted King D4 right even
against King E2 but it's the same same
thing after King E2 or king1 the problem
with King D4 is white plays King D2 so
he takes the
opposition and all of a sudden our King
is blocked out we can't we can't
penetrate so imagine this position King
D2 King D4 if it's White's move it's a
draw but if it was his
move sorry if it's if it's Black's move
it's a draw but if it's White's move we
win because no matter where he moves his
King he gives up ground we go the other
way so is there a way which we can get
that position but with white to move
so remember King D4 King D2 that's a
draw it's black to move right so we need
to get this position the Kings opposing
each other but it has to be White's
move yeah Patrick I was thinking along
those lines too
but I think I think black could I think
black has a way to win there also but
maybe not maybe I just missed
something no but King D4 we just said
that's it allows King D2 We don't want
to allow this position with black to
move we need to get this position King
D4 King on D2 with with White's move so
that way whichever way he moves we go
the other way and continue entering into
his
position so again look at all the
squares we have access to we know it's
not King D4 we can move to a square
that's close
by yep good job guys in the
chat
c yeah very good King
C4 so we go there and now after King D2
so he he can't delay this so if he goes
King E2 we would just go King C3 and
we're gaining
ground next move is King moves we we
enter to D3 and we're going going to
slowly get to the E3 Square which would
allow us to pick up this
Pawn so now what do we do after King
D2 we've got our position what do we
play yeah very good King D4 and now it's
White's move he has to concede ground
the game's
over we enter
here and we need to realize that this
position is winning once we get to the
sixth rank his King can't prevent
Black's King from entering so no matter
what he
does eventually we're going to end up
here he loses the F Pawn and he loses
the game all right now let's go back to
this line
so when we were thinking about ef4 King
E2 I thought King C4 was just the
simplest because we get this line that
we got after King E1 and eventually our
King our King penetrates
but oop sorry King E2 King
E5 maybe this move wins
also
uh H so I'm curious this does this win
after so the in the tactic like it gave
us ef4 King E1 they tried King E1 so I'm
curious would king E5 win here does this
make a
difference cuz maybe that's why they
tried King E1
then so does King E5 work here is there
a difference with the King on E1 let's
see I think I think there is yeah there
is so white goes king2
back and the point is he sticks
here so for example even if we get the
king all the way over here we can't make
progress and another point is
after by playing King
E1 King E5 King E2
this idea is no longer
possible we get the wrong position with
our move here we want this position of
white to
move but I think after King E2 King E5
also wins
now because the difference is
here
H King
E1
I don't know maybe there is no
difference actually now I'm looking at
it but yeah I
think yeah I think the point is just
that white keeps his King here to run to
G2 to defend if you try to come around I
think that's the point he doesn't try to
chase after our pawns like this he just
passively defends yeah I think
eventually we have to go for this idea
with King C4 to triangulate and then get
the uh King D4
position yeah sorry about that it was a
bit confusing for me there I don't
know Pawn in games can be
tricky all right finally back to Middle
game white just took on
F7 it's our move our Queen is under
attack there's potential for exchanges
here so what do we
think yeah Patrick that's what is
stripping me up as well
like I thought that if we mess up that
opposition it could just white could
just make a draw or something but may
maybe not I don't
know okay very good Rook takes E1 so we
start with the forcing move he captures
Rook he takes back we notice this Knight
on F7 could be potentially offside right
that Knight is is really deep in enemy
territory and it's not defended so Rook
E1 Bishop
E1 Queen
E6 double attack on the E1
bishop and the F7 Knight and he can
protect both all right they try Knight
G5 hitting our oop sorry hitting our
queen and king but we just take back and
we w a
piece all right we got a rook end game
now pwn out over the board everything is
flying so Black's last move is A4 he's
trying to get rid of this B Pawn so you
can have three connected pass pawns and
just start pushing stuff down the
board so should we be fixated on that or
what's our source of counterplay
here I've only got one thing going for
us
yeah good point Edward in the previous
position yeah D4 Bishop F5 good good
stuff yes very good point that's why
Queen E7 didn't work I didn't mention
that but yeah good catch
so again what's our idea here what's our
main pride in the position we only have
one thing going for us we're down
material he's got a bunch of pass pawns
ready to barrel down the board we have
one hope
here well if we give a check that
doesn't really do much right he just
moves his King and then
what our source of counter playay here
is not going to be that Rook we have
something
very which could potentially be very
strong for us in this
position again look at our
pieces okay one at a time which move
take the pawn well if you take the pawn
what does that accomplish he just pushes
the B
Pawn sorry what to run the pawn yeah
exactly we got this H Pawn here down the
board we can't like
get exactly we take on A4 we just give
him this Pawn like he already has enough
pass pawns we don't need to give him
another one we got to focus on our
counterplay here so let's start
calculating H6 we're about to run this
Pawn down the
board is there any way black can stop
this only way he can do that is to get
his Rook back in time so let's say he
plays a takes
B3 maybe hoping to get in Rook A7 so H6
ab3 we just pushed that pawn again he
can't stop that pawn so now his only
hope is to try to
Queen at the same time as us to counter
that so B2 we promote he promotes so now
okay let's visualize that position we
got a queen on h8 he's got a queen on B1
but we Queen first so we have that extra
Tempo which means we have to go for mate
there Black's King is
exposed so what do we play in that
position after both sides
promote check
where with the Rook
yes I think we have a better move again
you don't want the king to escape to B5
if his King Gets behind his own pawns
they're going to provide
shelter
H6 sorry what queen d8 uh you mean E8
here Queen can go to d8 or I mean
D1 right
uh sorry D1 how no I I think you have
the right idea they H6 promote so we
both
promote we gotta stop the king from
running that's Black's plan there so
which Queen check box is that King
in yeah very good E8 yeah Queen E8 so H6
ab3 H7 we promote he promotes if that
King comes down the board here sheltered
by his pawns it's
over he's up what two pawns but he's
also got a bunch of connected pass pawns
we have nothing going for us in this
position so we have to play for m here
Queen E8 check and the king is just
going to get mated very quickly so let's
let's see how that plays out king
B6 let's finish off the game here how do
we made him few ways to do
this okay Rook
B8 uh let's see I go back
here okay
yeah that's good Rook B6 and it's m the
king uh can escape so let's look at one
more potential line Rook B8 if I go King
A7
um actually not sure if this is leading
to mate now that I think about it uh
maybe Rook B8 wasn't the best way to do
it Queen B8 King C6 King's kind of
running
now but we do have this at least Queen
E6 check hitting the rook and the king
in the worst case we're picking up that
Rook but I think
back
here we have
a a simpler way to do this which I think
it's me or missing
something
uh okay I'm confused now I was thinking
this is made but King A5 maybe it's King
escapes unless I'm missing something
obvious Queen a king B5 somehow his King
is holding on here I don't know maybe
I'm missing a m but in any case this
line is good enough because we do pick
up his Rook here that's important Queen
E6 check that's enough for us to stop
the
line pick up the rook and then his King
will be exposed anyways we'll just be up
a
rook uh okay let's go to the next
position okay complicated stuff
but got to cut through the noise
here white has a bunch of scary looking
pieces but maybe they're not that
scary
so we have this
potential pass B Pawn here which could
be a source of counter playay if the
Queen's got off the board that pawn is
rolling down the board unfortunately
there a bunch of threats to our King
right now Knight just took on H7 he's
threatening to move that Knight give a
nasty discover check to F6 that would be
mate if we take on
H7 he gives a check King
G8 Rook d8 check we have to take
queen d8 king F7 and queen f8 is
mate so we can't take that Knight
either so are we all out of Hope or do
we have a counter counter move
here so again look at this seventh rank
this is potentially weak for
white The Rook on D2 is covering it but
maybe it's also a a Target
here
okay Queen takes D2 what if they
take yeah Rook comes down to
C2 and we pin the queen back and all of
a sudden White's just completely lost if
he takes on C2 all right let's make the
move yeah if he takes on C2 we take back
that Pawn's promoting and there's really
nothing else he can do no matter what
we're going to take that Queen and then
we're going to push this B Pawn down the
board and get a new Queen with a
completely winning position so yeah
Queen takes D D2 there nice little trick
taking advantage of The Rook sliding
down to the seventh rank all right we
got time for one
more this looks like something out of a
Greco game from the
1600s so Black's King is in the center
White's pieces are all attacking we are
down a piece though at the moment right
we got one two three pieces he's got one
oh okay I can't count never mind we're
not down a piece we are down some
material right one two 3 four five six
we got six pawns he's got seven that
means we're down a
pawn so we sacrificed the pawn here
somehow for some
initiative right we've got this pin
going on the H4 d8 diagonal Our Queen is
active got a knight in the center
pressuring that Knight on
E7 St way which we can exploit all of
this yeah it was Queen takes D2 it
wasn't just a you know desperate move to
give up the queen it actually had a
follow up to it with Rook
C2 D takes
E5 I feel like we have to use this pin
somehow so let's see this is tricky
there's no obvious answer at the
moment I have an idea I don't know if
it's good though
some good suggestions in the chat as
well haven't solved this myself either
so let's try to figure this
out got that pin going for
us and as the chat's pointing out
there's potential there are potential
mating ideas for example a move like
Queen H6 very cool move if black takes
we give a check King f8 Bishop H6 would
be made but he doesn't have to take
that's the
problem he could just take on D5 there
and we would just be lost if we take the
queen he takes Our Queen so Queen H6
doesn't quite
work so one other suggestion Bishop
takes E7 Knight takes e and queen
E5 we do get the pawn back and we have
this pin but not so
sure King f8 there maybe he breaks the
pin protects
G7 might be he might be escaping I think
we have something more incisive
here okay Bishop F6 another very
interesting
move
uh so what if black castles
there let me go into it so Bishop F6
Castle
so do you see a win for there do you see
a win there for white I don't see it
unless I'm missing something which is
possible this position is actually quite
tricky especially for the last one of
the
session so I'm I'm right now thinking
about an idea that's connected with
taking advantage of this
pin love to be able to take on E7 the G6
Knight is protecting it
knight6 Knight of6 he just
takes and we didn't get anything right
so I'm thinking about a way to undermine
this G6
Knight but I don't know maybe that's bit
farfetched
also might be off base there I don't
know this one's
tough yeah so I'm thinking about Bishop
D3 here with just the idea of taking on
G6
but not really sure how much of a threat
that is he could just take back fg6
hitting hitting the queen with
Tempo Rook E1 Rook E1 okay that's a good
suggestion getting the Rook into the
game
uh
maybe black plays Bishop E6 trying to
obstruct the E
file I mean whatever the move is going
to be it's going to be something like
very
direct it's probably going to be
sacrificial
somehow so yeah maybe maybe moves like
Bishop D3 on Rook E1 or too slow I don't
know this one's
tough
Bishop
H Bishop H six also very good good idea
but he just castles he doesn't have to
take on H6 that's the problem and I
don't see the
followup what do you guys think in the
chat really threw a curveball with this
one so we got a lot of candidate moves
we got Bishop F6 we've got Rook E1 we
got Bishop D3
I keep wanting to try KN six like he
said yeah yeah that would be great if we
could play KN of6 but fortunately there
he takes but then you take back bishop
and then he's got to move the Rook then
right and then you take
that I I just feel like that that would
turn into something well even if you
even if he plays Rook G8 you take on H7
everything is protected is Knight
protects the Rook more importantly after
Knight F6 gf6 Bishop F6 he's got this
queen takes D4 move our Pawn is hanging
that's a check then our King is very
exposed all of a
sudden so I don't think that a six Works
yes so again this suggestion Bishop E7
Knight E7 Queen
E5 also could be possible it just
doesn't look as forceful as I think this
this position should
be but could be just something simple
like that I don't I don't feel like it
is
though so like after Queen E5 there King
f8 I don't see a great followup
there we might have to
guess this yeah but again he takes and
then what he doesn't have to take with
the Knight right so Queen takes I just
take with the pawn if you take this I'll
move my queen up Queen is safe
then so if you take on C7
there so Bishop B7 Knight E7 Queen E5
King f8 you play Knight takes C7 I'll
play Knight C6 hitting her Queen back
I'm also attacking D4 potentially could
be an
issue
why do they have to give us such a tough
one
H I honestly have no
idea guys in the chat you're going to
have to bail us
out so my initial idea of Bishop
D3
I thought it was strong at first the
idea of Bishop G6 but even if he plays a
move like Queen D7 something weird like
that just to break the
pin I didn't see what we can play
there technically this is supposed to be
I mean the I think the club's puzzle
account is around 2700 and I set this to
I set the difficulty level minus 600 so
it's supposed to be around 2100
technically so it's pretty bad if we can
solve
this but this feels harder than a 2100
position there are no obvious moves
here Queen H6 I don't think that's it
guys Knight takes
D5 he doesn't have to take on
H6 yes Bishop F6 makes more sense
because we have a threat on G7 and he
actually can't take CU that's mate so
Bishop F6 my thing was I didn't see what
to play after
Castle protecting the G7 Pawn maybe we
just take on E5 there D takes C5 that
could be something so Bishop six castle
maybe just a simple D takes C5
recapturing and reinforcing that Bishop
he can't take again because it's mate KN
F6 Queen
H7 Bishop F6
Castle D takes C5 could be something
again it looks very lame though we just
take back after all
that surely there's something
stronger
uh oh wait maybe bishop F6 Castle Knight
E7 Queen
G5 so Bishop F6 Castle Knight E7 knight7
Queen G okay I'll tell you what I got
I'll tell you what you guys what I
missed so Bishop F6 Castle Knight E7
Knight E7 Queen G5 i' had seen this
early on but I didn't see what to do
after
H6 he the bishop takes first how can
Castle uh where Oh you mean here yes oh
no but we're playing Bishop F6 okay so
Bishop F6 Castle Knight yeah Patrick
exactly no Patrick's got it so I missed
Knight E7 Queen G5 H6 so the point is if
we take that Knight he takes back we
take that Queen he takes back it's equal
material but there's a very simple simp
move there so let's actually play it's
definitely Bishop F6 okay it's not
Bishop
F6 okay I give up then all right well
let's look at this line uh okay wait we
still need to input the correct
move uh shoot I don't know what to play
if it's going to be Bishop D3 I'll I
I'll be
mad okay it's not Bishop D3
good okay let's just guess moves
guys oh my God it's actually Bishop
takes E7 Queen E5 whoever said that good
job ni you should have the gym title not
me so Queen E5 I don't know I didn't see
what to do after King F though I didn't
realize why this is so
special like we won the pawn back but I
just didn't get it like does it just one
us to play Queen takes C7 and just win a
pawn it could be something like that cuz
that would be a very strong end game
right we're up a pawn and we got these
pawns as well but it just felt like the
nature of the position we've got this
pin or Queen's at that they wanted
something more forceful
see yeah wow it was just Bishop takes E7
and queen takes E5 interesting all right
so Bishop
F6 so why I rejected this early on was
H6 but what did I miss
here yeah Queen takes G7 it's just
m CU we're also threatening the Knight
on E7 he can't deal with both but now
that I'm looking at it I also missed
something else very simple and basic
Queen takes D4 check he has this counter
check which forgot about as well so
that's why this doesn't work otherwise
Bishop F6 would win but unfortunately as
Queen takes D4 check King doesn't or
King doesn't really have any good
squares and he breaks that pin wherever
we move our King oops he blocks that M
threat is Queen's out of that pin and
yeah Bishop's not looking too smart
anymore it's actually
trapped okay so I guess we could have
solved this with process ofation if he
realized all these moves doesn't work
then yeah Bishop takes C7 is probably
the move Knight E7 Queen E5 all right
that was a biz our position but at least
we figured out the the correct move
eventually after getting it wrong a
bunch of times all right so that's going
to be it for tonight thanks guys you
guys did really well uh good job in the
chat as well especially the guy who got
Bishop E7 Queen
E5 very well done uh hope you all enjoy
that uh have a good night uh we'll be
back next
[Music]
time
he